this is Hart cliff in South Bristol and
we're out on patrol with the police it's
one of the city's most deprived areas
and deprivation goes hand in hand with
drugs police here
a desperate to break the cycle of crime
they know cut throughs they know Gardens
they know what gate works what gate
doesn't work they know what fence they
can jump what fence they don't jump day
in day out the police carry out parades
some days I'll uncover cannabis
factories on others it'll be drugs dens
in Bristol they seize around the gram of
heroin every single hour but it's
suspected dealers that they want off the
streets
cracking Gehrig's PA and out on patrol
today they may have found just that
there's some rats there which will be
crack I expect and then in this egg
there's some more rats could be crack or
heroin than that I find it well you know
pretty rates up when I'm joking
I know people but dealers may supply
addicts that summer warning that with
fewer rehab options now available the
situation on the streets will only get
worse
take Simon for instance he's been in
prison but is now homeless and is
desperate to get clean he admits he
spent up to 400 pounds a day on drugs it
was addicted that's funny
started something sold for the best part
of 15 years for untouchable or just
greediness
to be honest I'm truthful Jones madness
now it gets me a bit well you know mean
appoint me away on routine
I mean free meals Nate indeed lots of
users are in and out of prison but some
do want to get clean at rehab facilities
like chandos house in Bristol this
residential clinic offers addicts a
chance to learn new skills but it's due
to shut its doors in a matter of weeks
because of funding cuts and it's not
alone new figures obtained by the rehab
provider you cat show 30 percent of
publicly funded drugs rehab centers have
closed in five years and they partly put
that down to funding cuts of 60 million
pounds in that time period many like
Anthony Corbet's he's currently
receiving treatment believed rehab
closures will lead to an increase in
drugs related crime most of these guys
in here right there we drop each other
we'd stop each other you know I never
fought about the consequences my family
they didn't stop me even though every
time I went to the cash point in my head
when I'm sorry I'm sorry but it still
didn't stop me and if I can't you know I
can't work for the money I'm gonna get
it from somewhere else this yeah indeed
back out with the police and we're in
pursuit of a car that's believed to be
driving dangerous we find it and block
it in but the driver crashes into us and
speeds off we follow
ten minutes later rich manages to track
down the suspects in a nearby cafe one
of them throws the phone to the other
and makes off with it
no drugs are found but a man's arrested
on suspicion of dangerous pride it's not
long before the police are back out on
the streets carrying out stop and
searches and catching those in
possession some insists that would less
and less support available for users
they'll simply end up in and out of
prison but the government says it has
invested 16 billion pounds in the
current spending period now you know
about your appointment all right so that
councils can offer drugs treatment
services Rebecca Williams Sky News